dans le cadre de la deuxième édition du
concours culinaire 100% féminin les
saveurs des îles vanille ont été mis à
l'honneur à l'espace réglé dans le bas
de la rivière à saint denis
des dégustations ainsi que des ateliers
gratuits ont été mises en place durant
trois jours pour le public
une manifestation organisée par
entreprendre au féminin océan indien
réunion avec le soutien du conseil
départemental
on est présente sur le site donc
l'espace réglée du conseil départemental
pour justement faire valoir donc les les
produits du terroir leur savoir faire et
que le public réunionnais puissent venir
à leur rencontre et de et de les
rencontrer et de savoir un petit peu ce
que proposent les autres pays nous
accueillons donc toute la délégation
régionale donc les lille les îles soeurs
ou les îles vanille on va dire ça comme
ça il ya que excepté seychelles qui n'a
pas pu se déplacer donc nous avons
mayotte madagascar les comores
rodrigue et maurice bien sûr où la
réunion qui est ici un véritable moment
de partage un échange interculturel
culinaire autour des produits du terroir
de chaque île de l'océan indien alors
déjà donc la cuisine n'a pas de
frontières il est prêt c'est un thème
fédérateur et d'autre part sa ferme et
comment les échanges j'espère
très intéressant puisque donc culturelle
également également une culture ou une
civilisation à travers sa plaisir un
honneur pour ces femmes entrepreneurs de
pouvoir faire découvrir leurs
spécialités au public mais également de
promouvoir la place des femmes dans
l'économie
nous sommes une petite confiserie
artisanale donc sur la réunion à sainte
marie ont produit d'essentiellement des
produits à base d'oeufs
d'aromates en fait de plantes
aromatiques de confiture et de fruits
épicés donc là c'est un point de
rassemblement qui pour nous semble
intéressant pour nous faire connaître et
faire connaître les produits donc ils
peuvent s'associer beaucoup dans la
cuisine au niveau culinaire donc soit en
association soit carrément pour cuisiner
avec en fait donc on a vraiment des
produits un petit peu spécifique là
dessus et puis bah si faire connaître un
petit peu le réseau et foires je pense
que c'est important de voir les femmes
entrepreneurs notamment alors le butin
fait c'est de travailler l'océan indien
ensemble défaire des échanges entre nous
donc exposés montrent et hoarau rayonner
les produits maoré et vice versa pour
qu'on puisse travailler ensemble à
l'avenir
alors je participe en fait justement
pour faire découvrir mes macarons à
l'ancienne aux saveurs de la réunion
voilà à saint-denis justement parce que
moi je suis du tampon donc
donc voilà pour pour élargir un petit
peu
donc les horizons impôts comme ci a
invité les réunionnais pour venir
oeuvrer pour gagner plus se passe à
rouler les produits qu'on à rodrigues
goûter et visiter les châteaux autorise
ces convois les citer aussi pour les
échanges en personnel aussi les amitiés
et contacts tout ça